okay
this is interesting never played a role
like before for the very first time and
this one's a new one
called rogue book
and it's made by the folk the dude
richard garfield who you might know as
the person behind magic the gathering
thank you for building roblox now they
have recovery of the doom coin you can
enjoy complete run
certain area certain content has been
locked under two releases two more
heroes a skill tree
interesting
epilogue levels heroes and locks are
kept at level six
make sure to come back on 24th of june
for the final release
okay um
never played this game before i'll email
this key by
pr folks and i tend to really enjoy
roguelikes because it's really
something that
do not know what will happen and you
really make the best of what you're
presented with so let's get into it
continue
does progression do
euros oh okay you can see how how far
hero is
seems we have four heroes here
back button let's go through the new run
[Music]
the forest means you of urano
i have no idea how this game works but i
guess
i need some help with this
okay
need some help
so rocco is versatile his poke body can
help shield allies from harm
all his powerful legs can help him deep
into the back okay
let's recruit
meeting you here
i do much i think i have to go to gate
[Music]
lead danger
let's bring the rope book inside the
robot here's your brush to print the
wall around you
find treasures and gems to power your up
your heroes and stand against these
enemies within these dangerous pages
the strong deck this is a deck building
rogue-like
and
care manager stays in the front line
which looks more effective okay
interesting
hey we got three chapters
let's give let's give it a shot
i don't do i have gold yes i do have
gold it's up here 100 gold
let's check out the wizard
game seven rock retainer hand
i have no idea what all these mechanics
mean
okay
look at our card deck i guess
strike oh strike is pretty standard i
think in most roguelikes
lunge
strike defend guard
craft anything
100 gold
[Music]
oh i can't move unless i
i
press space
to see what happens
okay
[Music]
keep some gold give you more territory
if you go to that one where it gives me
a bit more
vision as well
tower
enough to reach it yes i do
okay we actually have enough to buy
something let's go back to the shop
okay if i get the same items as well
sharers power
character certain gain one and loses
tackle coverage
okay
[Music]
okay so here's the tank
try
and their relics as well which i think
are
similar
to modify us and help change the game
trying to avoid this
burst powder draw card game fortitude
and go to its cost
[Music]
okay tell you what um
building a game cards that cost
low
low casting cost i think definitely
would be good
and
let's go for stuff that is free
okay
my thundering is
is pretty
fat now
see how this goes
oops
there we go
first battle
so it seems that there's raw orders
similar to gwent and
healthstone
if i can change the order
okay he's going to deal with 8 damage
and i have
abilities
okay let's draw a card first
one or two
and a seven ten game four block and lose
a stack of altitude
[Music]
oh individual cards are for individual
forks as well
so if i were to put up this
don't take any damage
let's attack
[Music]
last week
against me
it's gonna
attack
so
let's go
[Music]
it's 14 damage
it's quite a bit
any damage i think you can do this
let's go for war crying
and
[Music]
doesn't matter of course surrogate is
the best you really can try to get in
front
[Music]
13 damage
oh i can kill him ready oh no but he's
guarding
doesn't make sense for me to
smoke over one defense
[Music]
okay let's get this other way
that was fun
oh new item end goal
it was pretty straightforward
let me see how i can get into the battle
order differently
oh looks like 14 cards lost anything
cuts oh so there is a benefit to
actually getting more cards
can i get
the odd game on the change
it's a principle ui
can we tell much
to the front
oh
he moves the front if he gets
defense
cutting him to the front
[Music]
let's yeah
we should be doing okay
strike him strike him we're gonna push
her to the front
oh right now
[Music]
this roku is pretty tanky and you don't
heal up after each round so
gotta be careful there
to power
front
i think it should be done
extreme damage
that was fun
okay i've got ink um
let me clear one more one more battle
since you've got the jump
more crying
wow still sleeping
okay then
oh 18 damage
if only the block could really
[Music]
only the block could
carry on the next next level
no
increase the animation speed
it's a bit slow
[Music]
i should be able to complete this
around 19 damage
6 12 18
no i don't have enough damn
[Music]
okay
this guy's hit pretty hot
overtone whenever i equipped me to
replace the car
you can see further than it i can
one two three four five
[Music]
do i have to face just in case
oh what a waste
[Music]
oh
okay really does look that
you can't really open as much spaces to
clear
uh bosses or whatnot and because you are
limited by the amount of space you can
go
[Music]
let's try this
oh this isn't too bad
typically for roguelikes i tend to pick
stuff that deals more damage cause
blocking
you're going to cut there if you can't
really draw the stuff that you need
um
so i guess i'll just go for more damage
then
seems great
still have two chances right go back to
him
oh it's the same cards
okay i can't afford this
drop more cuts
[Music]
oh it's a dot
buckle up
you know this
damage taken
this much damage to distance to the
front
oh
it's pretty expensive okay since we are
working hard let's try
valentine oh new
[Music]
okay let's go for more
more
more flexibility
oh googie was a pretty expensive car
that i saw
activate game two
do i have so much that cars
good hmm
let's give it a shot
well probably whenever
this takes damage
boost two power increases to damage
okay
so this
defender bring him to the front
wait hang on
we have
16.
change 15 does she get more damage
i think it makes sense to bring it to
the right because you'll lose damage
anyway
wow
she's gonna go down if this happens
he actually costs three i'm gonna
activate him in two let's try this first
[Music]
okay
and
let's go for buckle up
power
[Music]
and that's it oh
25 damage that's quite a lot
[Music]
put the juggles
i've got feeling i can't really manage
this
strong
fortitude
okay bringing to the front
oh i do really need
[Music]
16.
let's do this
and bring him back to the front again
she has a passive two damage anyway
while 37 that's big
okay
let's go with four crowns
buff things up bring her to the front
bring him to the front again
he may go down
he will go down
oh he went with seven damage left
she's gonna go 36 damage
i don't think i have enough
[Music]
although nothing i guess
okay
defend
i wonder if all the damage that he gets
descended
let's spread over to
chiara at the back
can we play
characters dying at soon still attack oh
[Music]
man me end this i don't think i have
enough time
[Music]
enemies more money brush
to move in what's this
damn
that sucks
okay let's see we can increase the game
animation
[Music]
i'm not in a good place to actually
fight the boss extending me to heal up
marco isn't exactly helpful
okay
drop another cut
i know my roguelike stagger seems to be
a free
free time to play cool
that isn't too bad
i can't go anywhere
oh
[Music]
and goku is alive again
given the witch i was killing me that
was oh
wow look at the amount of damage in the
hp these guys have
is fully blocked
sticky pencil
hmm
oh 52 damage that's like
massive
i don't think it's gonna end well
minute 20 damage it's pretty much
conclusion
okay
let's try again
okay that's pretty much a game of
broke book
and it seems that
in defeating i'll be unlocking more
cards but the bar seems really far
oh that's it it's very simple
progression heroes
okay
[Music]
put three
oh the scrolls that i get are for perks
here
original one hearts per chapter start
the game with additional goal
[Music]
not my additional talent here would this
be it
i don't think that really helps me right
now
okay let's try again
[Music]
the ui is ways important
you need a hand
let's do this
[Music]
okay the puffle boss is pretty much
still the same
let's go to the shop again unless you
have
give me the same same items
it's new again
charge
move to the front both heroes
into power
um
we know how this is played
[Music]
there is that item there
you really have to be really efficient
with how we use our
paintbrush
[Music]
isn't too bad
the watchtower is good
two more clicks and that's pretty much
it let's see do this
i don't think i'll make it that far
let's go drop the cut
wow
kudigara
protector is damaged slicer dropout zero
all right
let's go for quick symbol damage
and let's see what the first battle
gives
at least us i know how i can get the
sirocco in front
okay seems simple
total about
14 damage
expand
can strike
good
hmm
five damage
eight plus six is fourteen
okay let's keep this simple
charge
and defend
money enough
and
i should end this nicely found no any
damage taken
i do want to aim for that
oh no
did we hurt them
what
no
no thousand straight nine
three thousand straight right should be
good to use this
oh man
cheated
we'll go there later
let me get another normal battle
[Music]
oh these rope guys again
do maximum damage first
and
him to the front
i need to do 23 damage which is unlikely
so
let's bring it to the front
okay should clean this up pretty nicely
make it now
shower really goes to the front deals
more damage he goes to the back oh
goodness i hope they're okay
one real voice length
oops don't buy anything yet
let's see another
rocks at the back
hmm
oh that's nice
maximum damage to the
damage dealer
6 damage
[Music]
nice
mozzarella likes increased cut draw and
casting cost i think that really helps i
don't really see much combos or
combinations right now
all things considered we're doing much
better than the first game
oh no
did we hurt them
so more battles gives us ability to move
into new places
and
[Music]
i will get there
enough with enough turns
one two three four
okay there's no blockage ah there is but
i can clear this pretty nicely
issues nice
every equipped hero plays a card that
costs two or more game four block
hmm
this will go nicely with my earring
so buy more expensive cards with suroku
for my blog
okay these guys are gonna hurt and hot
the next one let's see how fast i can
take one down
damn not enough
18 damage that's quite a bit
i guess it's one strike and two guards
[Music]
oh no i do that
ouch
mistake
oh man
damage uh can i complete kill him no
i'll still need to
defend once
twice
and forward and strike once
six damage
[Music]
15 damage yeah
i should have enough
12 okay we got this
that's next
there's nothing really good
ranged oh okay it's a free card if it
from the back
i like it
okay i guess i really do need to use
this
why not
go
to
oh i have a way to heal up
let me see if there's any good cards
with 200 that cost two
um
because we have
this guy
this is what it
that's pretty much it
let's go drafting for one more card and
then let's go for battle
[Music]
all right
okay this works
one random ink can you draw one more
card
buy one more card
oh yes nice
it's only four block for next two
critical
um
not that good
it then nothing
but a good mainly better i don't think
it's about another
match
well this is ben
oh
whenever hero costume walking to block
eddie's into that
good bus
i'm going to bring him to the front
right now
it's a bit
i'm not sure how we're going to do the
next boss battle with such low hp
i can't even clear him
[Music]
okay
let's do this
him to the front again
[Music]
oh just made it
was the big one
this costs half as much pick
paintbrush more money and a scope
okay let's try one more
one more area
to open up
nice
[Music]
oh that is generous
thanks for coming
you can hit pretty hard
motors really is good for me to
have a lot of cards and then use it as
my finisher
that's pretty much all the moves i have
five steps in opposite directions
doing that i can try this
see if anything opens up
oh
okay let's do this
i am in a worst state has compared to
previously
what do you know
52 damage
okay i gotta move her to the front
but that means
i don't think i'm in a good state
[Music]
i use my gem
[__]
okay everything better isn't too bad i
didn't die the first time around
let's redeem the bird trick
choose the additional gem for more pages
wow the the leaf is pretty big
okay
let's try again
third run of our roadbook
see what a good cut
[Music]
the double damage was good
maybe i need to up my block
if i focus on my block cuts
take for zero five times
oh this gives me 30 damage
wow
i like that
right spend all your
money thanks for
sure
oh
this is the biggest
okay
let's go
one shotting enemies is the way to go
that was
fun flawless okay i'm getting the hang
of this
oh my name oh he'll save the heel for
later so that it is possible to actually
heal
[Music]
oh man that sucked
and there's more heals
cut
is pretty expensive
let's go for something cheaper
okay so rocco picked away
seven damage
easy
oh no did we hurt them
too much brush
fuel space is a three tower range
oh this big let's find a nice spot to
open up
26 damage
30 31
don't have enough
still speculating
damage
thanks
six damage
i can take my time easier this
the card draws yeah so much better
compared to earlier
and let's push
[Music]
oh this is so much better
why do the
good stuff have to be at the corners
takes bonus cards from damage that
dissolve
treacle
let's buy some cuts
seems good man
this is good
showers are really my damage dealer
hey cool
has been locked
oh it changes all the time
plugging hunter
let's try this
okay this is a new enemy
the
seen before
spirit
aggressive software
heroes um
okay let's go with this
damage
and
so much
debuff
oh your nice isn't too bad
14 damage can i deal 30 straight away
10 minutes or 10.
that makes it 20
18 damage
18 damage plus 4
oh i don't think i have anything good
the block
and strike
should be able to wrap this up
nice
that was fun
okay my symbol combo is pretty much
adrenaline rush into a hammer
if no one's attacking
got two heels here
again again
okay let's go for the elite
see how it
goes it's going to whoa it's a
difference it's not the witch
wow this is a lot of damage
8 damage 13
[Music]
there's a lot to juggle
and it pretty much brings down
a shower if anything
okay
gotta figure this out
strike strike i can't take out one
damage
okay can do this
rush
right
track
oh
alright guys this enemy continues
getting 4 power and skipping the next
turn
okay it's hot
thirty
no it's more actually
okay let's go
36 damage that's a lot
[Music]
oh god
nasty
okay should be able to wrap things up
here if he does not get any block
emma time
favorite
i feel stronger
is that a copy to your hand
when do i play it
okay this had a copy craft
oh
this is how it looks
ah
that's how it works cut crafting okay
here we are going heal up
that felt great
highly helpful
let's just go buy some cards
[Music]
nice it's a very good block
hmm
oh no
oh well
let's go
the new is the new boss again
instead of each turn reduce the power of
hero by one last at the end of fight
16 damage he doesn't hit very hard
i think it's something that we can deal
with
oh crash
[Music]
we should be able to clear this pretty
easily
24 damage
let's go for adrenaline rush
tanker
it's gonna be painful though for him
12 damage
okay
to lunge to the front take a bit damaged
here
and
defend
18 damage i think she can take this
oh but it's double damage
[Music]
rush
yeah
that's good
[Music]
um let me juggle this nicely
okay take 4 damage
it's quite a bit of things i can do here
let me sum them
get the adrenaline rush for
four points and i can actually
[Music]
three points guard guard rush does that
make any sense
yep
20 damage i can do this here we go
that's what i'm talking about
oh yeah
first time completing a boss here
and we get an epic mock dash rose as a
battle and the random card of the
equipped hero to your hand cost zero in
this battle
circle energy okay let's go with this
because it's a zero cost
card and i think he spends quite a bit
of money what's this
[Applause]
take the enemy leading enemy for damage
you go to your block
oh this isn't too bad
they only have several crawl
wow all right
more cards
more talents
and
heels up yay
more damage
let's go
oh when will he
think he will be leading quite a bit
more cuts is good
let's see what that's a shot
treasure
i think you can roll better
seems good man
[Music]
brush really makes more sense
i'm going to go up further and faster
was this one nearer
this one is nearer
let me clear this first
you can lose more than wow
wow
isn't very cool
they do
oh i gotta troll stuff away
um
[Music]
wow that's massive
huh
when they do that
ouch
mistake
[Music]
ah
that was a bad
not very good
on my part
i'm gonna miss transforms my cuts
150.
let's get rid of clock
[Music]
nice
they can find it hot
[Music]
this game
okay i've got no
[Music]
not much options here life is pretty low
and i've got to make it to
the boss battle but this is
let's elite ahead and see what happens
155 damage
wow
so roku is going to be friend most of
the time i'm sure
rush
duke
tango
30 damage
oh this came pretty little
that wasn't too bad
i don't think i can even kill the elite
anymore
um 86
and i don't really have much moves
let's go and see what the elite can do
i also named there's a way for me to
actually change the order
instead of starting from the front i
mean this case is so cute
7.21 21 damage
you can do this
i can do this
do this
and i will save my critical damage
for next time
summer more enemies wow
oh damn i should use that first
[Music]
no mistake
well the fps for this game is pretty
full
okay bye breath isn't too bad
here's breakfast
oh enemies
that's good
you can barrage again
20 damage versus 15 damage
14 damage
still 18.
um
he's gonna go down
[Music]
whoa
don't think that's good anyway
but i got the scroll which is not too
bad better progress as compared to
earlier
let's see if i can craft anything
okay she's great
let's call this with clash
craft
let's see that hold the pause looks like
[Music]
400 damage wonder home does this even is
this even possible
isn't the last event you paid distance
to your hand
doesn't really tell me anything
it's gonna go down
when anything dies this enemy gains full
power wow
this is gonna deal with me 64 dimension
that's like most of the hp for here
for the enemies for my team here
it makes no sense
[Music]
the damage getting this is insane
a brush the brush humble works
[Music]
okay
wow okay
more cards attack for eight increase
this damage by three for each area
control
flex
wonder if i get discussed really
compression again
go to put tray
and you can spend stuff i can't really
do much because each purchase here
requires 10 or 30.
okay this helps me go further
i think that's not too bad
bad thing for that first
i'll start the game additional goal
okay let's decide later
you run
looking that's pretty fun i think it's
pretty good
but you don't really see much synergies
when it comes to the
lego
let's do this
[Music]
shop but let's see what we have inside
james gorsen's relics are
live
okay
maybe let's see for the relics instead
i got
i like it
i really like how
you are encouraged to get cards
or maybe to get as much cards as
possible
it's not really cool if um
you already open up anything on
significance
okay let's go sheepy folks hopefully
this time
okay we can do maximum damage
it's getting better i would say
after lunch i should be will complete
this
strike there we go oh goodness i hope
they're okay
not too bad
needless nice damage seems oh no
did we hurt them same damage has
launched my strongest right now
[Music]
can i even make it there
things are looking healthy
whoa this is a lot of folks for
nasty
i think for eat
whoa what happened now
this is me not reading the two tips
properly
six damage
okay i got the block up
that ability really makes sense for me
to get more allies and you can buy more
ally cards
[Music]
let me try this
strike
okay damage is not that high
twenty-five
[Music]
okay we got this
yes i don't get any strikes
that was fun
hey i'm not bleeding anymore
nothing here that's worth reducing the
cost of
um
let me go buy a car
hello
okay that's not the bet flattened
on this kind of cut as a result
no biggie
hmm
[__]
this stun is not too shabby
oh again just finish him off
nice
oh no
did we hurt them
she will craft more cuts to unlock
abilities
these are three cards that they missed
oh i love this style so cut this helps
me
um
[Music]
okay it's very um
here
don't we do much options really
oh
to 5.
should we buy more allies i don't have
any
finds the witch again
this takes damage to power distance
that didn't really matter
all things considered
um
getting the savings
[Music]
i feel stronger
foreign
[Music]
i guess this is the time whenever
you play midi card deal 10 damage i
don't know what's a mini card
we have to get him in front to load up
peace
i have a feeling this one end well
really need to be a bit more hard
hitting
this is it
huh
[Music]
longer this battle goes the weaker she
becomes
i'm back baby
okay let's
finish this up
[Music]
as much i can do
oh this is a pro round
hmm
oh man
okay let's go new run
didn't really have much good luck of the
draw for that
do the gems are pretty alright
[Music]
feels like quite the
distance just trying to open up as much
as you can
[Music]
that's pretty far
metal
so
uh
i really like how you really need to
strategically move your guys to the
front line and back and how it juggles
there it's very similar
to
quite a few roguelikes
i don't really like how the cards don't
give him as much options
in terms of damage and abilities
uh
let's start
review
oh what's this
scroll oh it's a freebie
okay nice this run is pretty solid for
the start
i shouldn't be losing any hp in this
[Music]
oh goodness i hope they're okay
no
how did it pop up
14 damage that's quite a bit
hmm
okay
the issue with this game is that there's
not a lot of sustain when it comes to
damage in general
for recovery
recovery is a bit scary because it's
random a bit too random for my liking
next leaders by your way we've got like
uh
campfires to actually rest
this doesn't
we should wrap this up pretty easily
on one lunge and a string
that was fun
oh these guys had hot
okay
a lot of pain in the next round
didn't need 24 lucky i got to brought
put the critical guy down
let's do a strike
and let's do a lunge
oh i have to cut double cut
let's go for safety
damage
24 damage
surely i spend my cards on my money on
cards before actually attempting these
guys
i think that should really have been the
case
also makes no sense it's taking way too
much
oh no
did we hurt them
okay let's heal up
again
[Music]
transmute the cut
let's go for free cards and
[Music]
what's the variability oh it's together
okay
nice damage
it's no block
hmm
doesn't really work out that well
thanks
[Music]
seems good man
all right
thanks
because i have
14 13
i need to find one more
crafting area
ah
okay let's go buy a cot
very specific
thankfully whenever game block this turn
deal
don't do bad
[Music]
okay
[__]
ouch
[Music]
wow
oh goodness i hope they're okay
she
[Music]
not a good
opening
what's up
[Music]
woof
second lara is not bad attacking and
then still deals damage
stand behind me
[Music]
okay got to
chocolate damage
actually i'll survive
hmm
i wish the shopkeeper gave me items to
heal
[Music]
okay it's not good
hmm
shoot
okay this is interesting
i think this can be managed oh wow his
buff means he eats it shall we
that was unexpected
19.
she has to be here right now
whoa
where did they come from
that wasn't a good run at all
[Music]
okay let me end the stream
thanks for watching guys